-Our next guest
is a talented actor
you know from such shows
as "Superstore"
and the animated series
"Chicago Party Aunt."
He stars in "American Auto,"
which airs Tuesday nights
at 8:00 right here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Cy-dawg! Heads up!
-Oh, my God, Oh, my God!
I'm in hell!
-You are officially invited
to join the pain fun patrol.
-[ Spits ] It's in my mouth.
-We're going to go around.
We're going to do fun things,
raise morale.
It'll be great.
-I need an eye wash.
Why did you have to do this?!
-Because this is
my family's company,
and if people aren't happy here,
then I'm going to fix it.
Welcome to the team.
Whoo!
-Please welcome to the show
our friend Jon Barinholtz.
Hey, Jonny!
-Heyyy! How are ya?
-Now, Jon, you were
supposed to be here in person,
and I would be deeply offended
by the fact
that you backed out to do
this show from LA via Zoom,
but you have
the best possible reason.
Four days ago, you had a baby.
-Yes. We had a baby.
We welcomed our second baby
into our family.
Yeah, it's very crazy.
I'm on very little sleep.
As of a week ago, I was
still planning on coming out.
We thought he was
going to be here early.
And as of, like, last Monday,
my wife was like,
"If he comes today or tomorrow,
I think you should still go.
This is our second rodeo.
Our parents are here helping.
And you'll have seven days
under the belt."
And then by Wednesday,
he still wasn't here,
and it changed from her saying,
"I think you should go,"
to, "I think you should still go
if you really want to."
-A very, very wise decision.
Was the birth uneventful?
Healthy? Everything good?
-Healthy. Everyone's good.
I was talking to my wife
about it.
Seth, it's so silly
to come onto your show
and tell a birth story.
You, like -- You're the GOAT.
You jumped the shark
for birth stories
for everyone
with the lobby birth.
-Yep. Absolutely.
And I did all the work.
-You did all the work.
It was all you. Congratulations.
No. Ours was very --
It was textbook.
We were in at 11:00 a.m.,
and by dinnertime, he was here.
There was one moment
that was pretty scary,
and it speaks
to who I am as a person.
At around, like, 5:30,
the doctor came and in was like,
"I think you have a couple
of hours left of labor."
We're like, "Great."
So I said, "Annika, hey, these
nurses have been so great."
Shout-out to Tarzana Providence.
Anabelle. She's the best.
I was like,
"They've been so great.
I'm going to order
a bunch of pizza for them.
Also for me.
What do you think?"
And she was, like,
on an epidural.
She's like, "I don't care.
Go do whatever."
So I ordered it,
and about a half-hour later,
the doctor comes back in
and checks Annika,
and she takes out the stirrups
and puts them up.
I'm like, "What's happening?"
The doctor's like,
"It's go time."
And right when she said that,
my phone dinged, and it said,
"Andrew P is out
with your delivery order."
Right then,
I was like, "Oh, no."
I saw these trains colliding,
and either, like,
this has to go faster
or Andrew P
has to get caught in traffic
because something's --
I haven't seen the movie
"Perfect Storm,"
but I think
it's about this situation.
And, I --
This is COVID times, too,
so you don't have friends
who can go down to the lobby
and bring food up.
It's just us.
So I pulled one of the nurses
aside, and I was like,
"Hey, I ordered a bunch of food
for everyone.
Is there someone who could
maybe run down and go grab it?"
She was like, "What?
No, we're insanely understaffed.
Get away from me."
I was like,
"Yeah, of course. Of course."
So, you know, 15 minutes later,
now we're in full push mode,
baby is coming out,
and my phone dings again.
And I don't look at it, Seth,
because I'm trying to stay
present for the birth of my son.
But at the same time,
I know what that ding means.
I know it's Postmates saying,
"Andrew P is arriving
with your order."
And one final push,
and the baby's here,
and he's beautiful
and he's healthy,
and we put him on my wife's
chest and we're all crying.
And my wife and I,
we look at him,
and she looks at me
and she's like,
"I love you so much."
And I'm like,
"I love you so much.
I'm so sorry.
I have to go run down
and get some pizza real quick."
And I did it.
I ran out of the room.
I got the order.
I said thank you to Andrew P,
because I'm a nice guy.
I brought it back.
It was all good.
They forgot one order of the
curly fries, but, you know...
-You know what? Let's not make
that what the day is about.
-That was my lobby birth.
That was my lobby birth.
-That's your lobby baby.
Hey, this show is a lot of fun.
Ana Gasteyer. Great cast.
We saw a little bit about --
So, your character --
you're the child of someone
who owns this auto company.
It must be fun.
-So much fun. It's another
Justin Spitzer show.
So, I did "Superstore,"
and that was a dream job
with an amazing cast.
I feel like
I'm right back in it again.
I feel so lucky to be
in another workplace comedy,
another amazingly talented cast.
And this is kind of the flip
of "Superstore."
"Superstore" was, like,
the workers on the ground floor
who are affected by, you know,
the bad decisions at corporate.
This is now
the people of corporate
making those bad decisions,
and we see how they exist.
-I did not realize that
you had some automobile lineage
in your own family.
-I do. I do.
On my mom's side,
we're a direct line
of the Studebaker family
of Studebaker cars.
And while that's like --
could be kind of cool,
there are three
Studebaker brothers,
and our line
is Jacob Studebaker.
And the brothers all got
together, you know, years ago.
This is, I think,
great-great-great-grandfather.
And they were like, "Hey, we're
going to start a car company."
And two of the brothers
were like, "Great."
And Jacob was like,
"I don't think cars
are gonna be a thing.
I'm gonna stick with farming."
[ Laughter ]
So he continued on to Ohio
and stayed in Ohio
and just became a farmer,
and our family was farmers,
and then the other brothers went
and had a giant,
successful car company.
[ Laughter ]
-We've known each other forever.
I've known you
since you were a kid.
Your brother, your older
brother, Ike Barinholtz,
a former roommate of mine,
a dear friend of mine.
How is Ike as an older brother?
How would you define it?
-Honestly, the best.
It's always been really great.
You know, he's six years older,
and I want that on the record.
I want everyone to know that.
Six years older.
-He looks 50 years older.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't wait
for him to see that.
He was very supportive of me.
Lie, by the end
of my college career,
I knew I was gonna --
I wanted to go back to Chicago
and do, like, comedy college,
so to speak, at Second City
and Improv Olympic
and Annoyance.
And I called him my junior year,
and I was like,
"Hey, I know what I want to do.
I'm done.
I want to go and do improv."
And he right away was like,
"Don't be an idiot.
You're a year away
from getting your degree.
Get your degree
just on the off chance that
improv comedy doesn't pan out."
He was like,
"Get your college degree."
So I'm very grateful that
I stuck around and did that.
I learned a lot that last year.
Yeah, but he's the best.
-Well, you come from a very
good family of Ohio farmers,
and it is wonderful
to have you here.
Congratulations
on your new addition.
Great to see you, Jonny.
-Thank you.
-Jon Barinholtz, everybody.
"American Auto" airs
Tuesday nights here on NBC.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."